oh i'm not a superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
[Music]
okay tatiana i have to say it i'm so
glad to see you in this congratulations
on the series
but i've seen you do genre orphan black
you had to do everything
comedy though like i'm glad you're doing
it but it's a really big leap what made
you want to really sort of dive into
that yeah i mean i've i've always been a
fan of comedy it's like my favorite
thing to watch and and i revere
comedians so when this script came to me
i i was laughing on every page i found
it so funny and i thought it was so
character specific you know it wasn't
just like a comedy that was jokes it was
like these weird characters kind of
bouncing against each other so it felt
uh like a good good in for me into into
that world it seems like the
mockumentary style has definitely come
up a bit so audiences are lit a little
bit more used to that sort of office
we're gonna turn away to the camera but
this show with this breaking of the
fourth wall that is a complete i think
departure from that yeah um but is that
like something like as an actor you like
relish in addition to the fact of like
you know getting to like kick butt and
show up mark ruffalo and all those other
things
yeah i mean for me the the address to
camera is like
this wonderful um expression of the fact
that she-hulk is so conscious
she's so aware of the
the structure within she which she's
operating um you know she knows there's
an audience and she's kind of looking
back at them
so much of this show is about outward
perception depending on the body that
you present how you're treated how
you're spoken to so for her to look back
at the people who are looking at her
feels feels like an engagement with that
exact you know idea that we're talking
about there's so much of that i mean
we're inside a woman's head which is
like such should not seem like a novel
thing but like not something that we
live in that much in like i think modern
television so it's so great this is on a
streaming service and i haven't even
talked about the big thing girl you're a
superhero like you literally legit like
have like like toys and stores oh yeah
you can play with yourself it is like
all there
but that's like a such a like it's a
badass thing right and she's the
ultimate badass so was it that that made
you want to do it was it kevin feige
sort of like knocking on your door
sliding through dms i know he does that
i know really apparently he does or he's
like peep twitter yeah yeah no i like
truly auditioned for this like i i yeah
and and that's
i i love auditioning in in the sense of
i love girl you are a rare breed
i mean it in the sense of when it when
it's when it is
when you do have an opportunity to
audition with people who are actually
watching that's a totally different
thing because our industry has gone in a
fully different direction where truly
all of my friends send tapes they go
into an ether and they never get
feedback and
so
the luxury of having the director there
and all of the execs as much as it's
terrifying it's like that's that's the
job that's what we why we do this so
yeah wow you guys went through this is
an old school sitcom i love that about
it i really love that it not only like
plays within the wheelhouse of sitcoms
but honors it doesn't make fun of it it
really was like no this is a really
interesting and one of that is like the
callbacks and yes sort of like there's
some real things that are like very
specific to sitcoms what was your
favorite sort of like i wouldn't say
trope but but part of that genre that
you got to play and that you
particularly liked
oh that's a cool idea um
oh i don't know
because you guys have a bunch you guys
have post credit scenes you have sort of
like catchphrases you have yeah yeah
fallbacks uh mysterious characters that
pop up and you don't see them for
forever and then they just pop up again
yeah you guys have all of that yeah
totally i mean i think yeah and tonally
it kind of even if we're like in the
courtroom it always keeps like dragging
itself back into like sitcom territory i
don't know i i like love elaine bennis
from seinfeld so for me she was like a
big touchstone for this character in the
sense of like she's like in the
corporate world but she's also like
stealing cake from her boss's fridge
like there's like this great combo yeah
of like super professional and absolute
disaster that i think is
you know they're beautiful
as long as she's beautiful i mean but no
but like but like when i say that is
like you really enjoy this mess yeah you
enjoy watching this woman fall apart oh
that is such a great way to put it like
no legitimately i like it like somebody
you enjoy watching fall down totally i
love that song it's like super human
super super space human not super human
but there you go that's none of the
world and again again superhero because
you're giving me a great segue thank you
for helping me no problem i saw your
notes before
i know exactly but yeah no that's the
super the human aspect of it but also
like the mo-cap aspect of it and what
you physically
have to shift on set i'm sure you've
gotten that experience from orphan black
literally duplicating yourself but what
was it like with this one sort of you
know your head is taller and they're
reacting to a different plane yeah it's
it's a totally different thing and and
it requires a different um
uh
like internalizing of
of who i who i look like um while still
maintaining jennifer because jennifer is
the same when she becomes she-hulk she's
just in a completely different body and
so it's really about how other people
respond to her and you know i'm walking
on these like platforms i'm taking up
all this space in a room that i'm doing
a scene in so i already feel
like
like like i'm taking up a pr you know
i'm taking up a space yeah and to me all
of that really informs how she-hulk
feels when she walks into a room that's
so cool i would love to just have your
job for one day and just be a woman that
could be like part the c oh yeah that's
that's enviable mark ruffalo we
definitely have to talk about him i
don't think it would be like advice but
i think it's more of like what did he
tell you about sort of coming into this
because i know you guys shot your stuff
with him yes early i believe yeah he was
just i mean he's so much about like
empowering other people's processes like
he would never you know tell me how to
be a hulk or anything but we did swap
stories and ideas around it and sort of
our own experiences um and i think we do
come to it from a different perspective
which is very helpful in the sense that
so do bruce and jen yeah but we also
have like i i have such a deep respect
for him and such a love for him and we
we both like to play yeah so so we get
that like kind of crackly you know
brother-sister banter thing that happens
um while also like getting to be in
mocap so it's it's it was really fun it
was special and let's honestly keep it
real the fact that like she hulk is
better at being a hulk because basically
the hulk didn't go to therapy and didn't
learn how to regulate emotions is like
testament to just how brilliant this
show is written yeah totally jessica gao
is well a genius people only care
because i'm representing emil blonsky i
think they care cause they're like hey
that girl's green
jen do your thing god i really like this
outfit
i'm not proud of this first of all i do
have to say your character is hilarious
and
it's like i i don't want to say it
because it's diminishing but like the
best friend is a role right and so like
it is a type of role to have but if
you're gonna do it do it like that right
thank you but did you sort of like
approach it that way because this show
definitely has those like sitcom vibes
yeah yeah yeah i mean i know yeah that
role can be so archetypal and it's like
there's so many dangers that come along
with it oh my goodness backstroke like
so i was like
she's gonna be rad you know and so i got
really involved in with her clothes and
with uh you know even with her hair and
makeup and i honored her style in a
specific way and i just i wanted her to
be really free and if i and i you know i
love people like bill murray i love a
lot of i love a lot of like these
characters that i've seen before that
are often played by men and they get to
go off and kind of say whatever they
want which is always fun to play so i
really wanted her to be that
non-consequential unapologetically
herself person that um that is still
really really based in love you know and
uh yeah and authentic still very real
like not a character like i mean
obviously you're playing a character but
she's not a caricature yes 100 of what
that could be although i will say in the
mcu they do have a pretty good track
record for best friends like they really
do like you
know oh my god ned i was i was literally
gonna go like cork but then there's also
um you're also talking about like bucky
and yes yeah and like that's two they
are like bucky gosh that's such a
dynamic part right yeah so of all of the
mcu best friends would you have one that
you would want to like bring into
she-hulk universe i mean even wong like
wong is in the god i don't know too so
you've already got no one i got blessed
with long trust me i would probably
choose though if if there's another
jew's ned because you know he's also
filipino and they finally put alola in
spiderman and it was like the cutest
thing ever and i would want to see his
family yeah we might be related i mean
what if i'm related to ned
are you writing this right now yeah like
because if we could make this happen
like we can make this happen
i do want to talk about you're bringing
a lot to this like like this is like a
continuation of the show because you
bring like jen through a lot like like
she needs
she really makes she does need jennifer
a lot and
so many things what do you most excited
about taking her through on this journey
because you are her best friend but you
are also like i think her driving force
well i love to see her win you know what
i mean i don't want to i don't want to
fail at this i don't want to be like hey
do all these risky things and really
embrace who you are and not have it pay
off you know what i mean so i it's it's
a gamble but i'm i'm hope it's all well
intended but i like to see her freaking
win i mean and you definitely push her
towards that and i would say win in more
ways than one like that's all i will say
any way that you can win right nicky is
gonna push covering all the bases okay
thank you thank you
um and i will say that is part of who
she is like you said she's very free
she's somebody that believes in love and
like legit and shares that with the
world right
but in that i would say like that
freestyle what would you say is her
philosophy because i think it comes
through in who she is but it's something
that's hard to quantify but you brought
it so like i think uh refreshingly on
screen to where i could feel it so how
did you sort of describe her what would
you say is her yeah i felt like nikki
was very um i felt like jen was book
smart and nikki was street smart in a
way that she understood people's
psychology and i feel like she's
probably been through a bunch of things
she's accepted how difficult it is to be
a woman in a world and she's like no
this is how i live my life and this is
what i'm doing but i do feel like she's
she's uh she's uniquely in tune with
with people's psychology whether she
really is acutely aware of it yeah and
so there's kind of this driving force
that's why she can kind of work with
anyone and and is confident that she can
kind of talk her way out of things and
know how to talk to people yeah oh i
really like that also like you get to
witness probably more than anyone in the
show just how good of an attorney that
she is
and just really how she advocates for
someone do you think there's anybody
accused of a crime or really any mcu
villain that she couldn't defend
absolutely not she hulk and glknh our
entire squad can help anyone the human
or superhuman but who would be difficult
i think the most difficult people would
be some some characters you will see on
our show that have yet to enter the mcu
until our show because we are a
superhuman law division so we can pluck
any superhuman out of the comic books
and throw them into our show and some of
them are freaking weird and difficult so
you have really just intrigued me so
much because i do not think those are
the episodes that i got to see no no
they're not and i don't think that's i
can't wait for you to see these actors
that embody these brand new roles that
haven't been in uh the marvel
mcu yet so get ready okay now
thank you for shocking me thank you so
much for shocking me you already
mentioned him once but i definitely want
to talk to the benedict wong of it all
and just his energy on set and what he
brings to everything like who even is
this man i love him so much like what a
light in the world truly like he's
everyone in his circle is so lucky he he
came you know jessica writes these roles
for these actors that are iconic and we
don't know if they want to be on our
show you know what i mean we're like oh
my god i can't believe they're here and
then they're there and they're happy to
be there and and giving so much and and
benny would bring
like also i have video one day he just
started djing on set and if and i'm like
oh that means he brought a setup from
london
he travels with these things and so he
would be djing in his long outfit which
is just please tell me this video you're
about to draw i'll just say that i
released it and then i got in trouble
for releasing it but then benny was like
where'd the video go and i was like i
think it's still out there because you
can't stop the music
um so i did get in trouble for it but it
does exist we would dance oh i mean you
know that now i'm like it's now i'm
gonna have to find marvel fans they're
gonna screen grab whatever they find so
i i
apologize i didn't know i wasn't allowed
one thing like sort of like leaving in
this obviously you're hilarious you've
cracked me up so much just in this time
here how much did you guys get to play
with that on set and improv because you
can really tell that you guys were
probably having just a blast yeah we
were really lucky and there's so many
improvisers you know and tatiana knows
how to improvise josh legra john bass
like renee lee school's very one of the
funniest people i've met my life like so
weirdly um even though there's all the
technical elements to it i think because
improv is inherently mostly verbal it's
still they're still it's still possible
it doesn't conflict with uh the
technical of it all so uh jessica like
let us play around and uh put our stink
on things and and and through and we
would do something then she throws
another suggestion so we just yeah we
got really lucky on this comedy
so i'm clearly nailing it at all these
things
[Music]
if you want to go back to your life as a
lawyer i i respect that
he doesn't mean that
first of all jessica congratulations on
the series i have to start this way
because i feel like this is really the
first time that we're going to see a
bona fide sitcom and a bonafide comedy
in the mcu and it is a sort of like
brave choice to also be one of the ones
that actually acknowledges the audience
outside of i would say the deadpool
series so what was that decision like
and why lean into it because it could
have easily been left out as something
that's difficult you know especially in
series there's no way i would have left
it
um because you know the john burn run
was my favorite run it was what made me
fall in love with this character and to
me that is the iconic run yeah um and so
to me
breaking the fourth wall is
quintessential she-hulk like that is
such an innocent inextricably linked
part of her character that there's no
way i would have made a show about her
without that it then it wouldn't to me
it wouldn't feel like she-hulk yeah and
i completely like basically i was like
giving you the license to be like no way
because there's different versions of
the character and she didn't always do
this this was very to that particular
point to that particular run and it also
teams up to this other nice thing about
it that it sort of sets up maybe the
idea for i would say more universes
within there maybe west coast avengers
is that one that
i mean i know you really couldn't say
yeah but i can't i know you could say
but is that something maybe you also
were passionately interested about and
uh studied a little bit i mean there are
so many things i was passionately
interested about
do you like my very well rehearsed
marvel answer my marvel safe answer i
really do love and i appreciate how much
they threaten y'all
one thing that's going to come out with
this series when folks sort of watch it
is the fact that in addition to that you
lean into one of marvel's big staples
which is the post credit scene um really
heavily with this one and they are so
pitch perfect and they really go to
incredible places i'm just curious how
much of that was planned out for each
episode like how far in advance because
really
i would say there's like key post-credit
scenes that everybody loves and you guys
really tried to hit it out of the park
with each one of these like that um i
love post-credits scenes like not just
in marvel like any movie that has a
post-credits scene i love it's always
you know it just feels like an extra
little treat you get at the end um and
you know our writer's room you know
we're all comedy writers so
like give us any chance to throw in
another joke and we'll take it of course
like we're we're never gonna stop so um
almost every episode has a uh
post-credits scene and those are always
some of the most fun things to come up
with i will say too they all sort of
have like a very unique identity how far
in advance were they planned or did you
sort of
approach each one on the filming
schedule like how did each one sort of
get set up or did they come organically
uh most of them were scripted um there
was only one that was written on the fly
and that was based on casting of um who
was in it okay
i you know exactly what i'm like i'm
like i think i understand and both y'all
are in for a treat i will just say like
if they don't get they can't tell
already you're in for a treat the other
thing i think folks are going to be
surprised about is how much you guys
really leaned into the case of the week
of it and just that idea of like you
know i think a lot of folks had said
maybe deadpool or whatever but i just
thought ally mcbeal in so many ways just
these different cases and they felt real
even though they were heightened so what
was the sort of process for picking each
one of these cases and where you guys
would each each time it was really fun i
mean we had such a great writing staff
and we had so much fun every single day
because really we spent so many weeks
just mining all the movies and um all
the comics and picking characters out of
there that you know we you know somebody
would be like well i really think that
they might be fun and then we had the
kind of thought exercise of
um figuring out like what is a character
specific reason why that person would be
in legal trouble you know and that's
always a fun place to start and it's
this built-in comedy engine for like for
funny stories very cool i guess the next
question would be is there anything that
you guys sort of workshopped um that
maybe even made it into the script but
didn't that we didn't get to see that
you're like oh man i wish we would have
gotten that one
i mean there's so many give us one maybe
like a little little bts easter egg of
one little one that we may have missed
i don't i would have to think about it i
mean it's just been so long you know
there's so many things i was gonna say
this is like the thing with the marvel
you guys kind of filmed these all sort
of at once and then have sort of like
expanded upon it but
i will say just of all the things that
you've sort of seen in the mcu and maybe
even she-hulk do is there anything that
you think folks should most look forward
to if they're familiar with it from
either the run or anything else like
maybe what should folks keep an eye out
for well you know i'm just really
excited to
uh
show like all the different facets of
superhero life that really honestly is
what i'm excited about like i'm excited
that we actually have a hero a marvel
hero who dates and like meets all these
different uh characters and gets to
experience like the full breath of like
a single woman's life that's actually
what i'm very excited about the other
thing i think is interesting too is
underneath all that she's also dealing
with a lot of the heightened idea of
like i didn't sign up to be a superhero
and also i really just want to do this
job and i'm passionate about these
people and this is all getting in the
way of that and then there's also some
of this like very broad comedy and like
all of it sort of mixes in together how
did you guys in the writer's room sort
of balance that as far as like keeping
it because they take big shifts in tone
but it's like you feel like you can go
along with the characters each time
um we had a uh very female heavy writers
room and you know like in any other uh
writer's room we're mining each other's
lives for ideas and for content you know
and as everyone starts talking about
their life experiences and like issues
that were affecting them um you start
seeing kind of like patterns and
commonalities and kind of common themes
of things that were like plaguing us in
the moment or just in our lives in
general and so those were kind of the
things that we would then put into uh
put into the show and some of those
issues kind of you know lend itself into
being kind of like heavier more
emotional topics because it's just real
and then there are other times where
like all comedy writers we deal with
trauma by with by using humor you know
and we're just masking our tears yeah
but you did it so well and i appreciate
you guys using those tears as fuel for
our entertainment let me just say that
your transformations are triggered by
anger and fear
those are like the baseline of any woman
just existing
oh
i'm gonna die
yes yes yes
no
no first of all congratulations on the
series i have to start here because it
seems like this was obviously a project
that anyone who knows marvel ip would
want to bring into something but how did
your journey sort of get involved in
this and being an ep and directing most
of the episodes um i had been talking to
marvel for a little while about finding
something to collaborate on together
because i'm a huge mcu fan
and when she-hulk came along it was a
no-brainer and i put together um my
vision for the show and it aligned
directly with uh the writers and the
producers at marvel and um it was off to
the races
one of the things the show really does
because although there's um a definitive
run um and the premier run of she-hulk i
think everyone sort of has their
different versions of her that they like
this one obviously leans into the one
that breaks the fourth wall but that's
sort of like an interesting comedy trope
that you don't get to explore too often
and so leaning into it heavily is like a
very big swing what was uh what was that
sort of like as far as directing that
and again you just don't see very many
actors come direct to camera like that i
mean
to me that is one of the fundamentals of
she-hulk she
along with superhuman strength has a
sense of self-awareness that i consider
to be another superpower and that
self-awareness reflects in the fourth
wall breaks and in the idea that you
know maybe there's somebody else uh
moving those marionette strings um and
so that was always um a part of the show
and it really became a question of how
much
how much
you know helps draw the audience in um
you know while still maintaining the
integrity of the world that we're
building and not breaking out too many
times absolutely i mean obviously folks
can sort of make a draw and inspiration
from the burn run but also just within
the dna of the show it obviously follows
very strict comedy sitcom rules and i
would say
also sort of encourages them with a lot
of i would say the sort of format of it
and the things that you guys call back
throughout the series so what do you
think about this particular show and the
style was the biggest inspiration was it
those rom-cons like ally mcbeal or was
it more i would say maybe more
fourth-wall breaking type shows like
that gosh it's such a mishmash of a
million different things the essence of
the character from the comics it was
first and foremost and then what i love
about ali mcbeal or legally blonde is
that they took a genre the courtroom
drama and they turned it on its head and
they subverted it and they inserted pink
and wildness and strangeness which we
obviously do yeah you know then there
are these fourth wall breaks that are
reminiscent of shows like fleabag and
deadpool but she's doing it way before
that uh and then you know my
responsibility as a director was to
honor the comedy but also draw from the
films and make sure this feels like it's
part of the language of the mcu that's
the other thing about it too is because
we've obviously seen like mockumentary
style presentations where folks are
talking to the camera but it's sort of
again like they know they're being
filmed and it's the presence and the
awareness the isolation of her being the
only person that is really sort of about
that is i think very different and it
also sets up you know i would say more
things for her to do within the mcu and
potentially bringing in different
characters that fill this out so i mean
i'm setting this up maybe or not but is
there anybody else you'd like to see
maybe come into this world maybe
somebody who also breaks the fourth wall
i don't know i'm not making any
suggestions i mean
ryan reynolds if you're out there
um
you know i look i think part of the
genius of the premise is that you're
in the real world at a superhuman law
firm and the real world happens to house
every superhero that's ever existed so
you could literally have every single
one of them go through the doors of that
of that um law firm
i mean this the other thing though too
you also have already brought over some
pretty cool folks from the law firm and
charlie cox and benedict guang i do have
to say adding in them just the
characters that use obviously mark
ruffalo as well i don't want to forget
about our original hulk too would have
been shot for that tim rock tim roth i
know but what was it about them that
that they felt right for this particular
story obviously mark has the general
connection but some of these other
characters it seems like you guys really
wanted to create an ensemble
absolutely i mean mark is such an
important part this is a story of a
woman um and a big part of her story is
family and he is family and they have
this sibling like big brother little
sister relationship um
and then wong i mean i keep hearing
people talk about the wong cu and we
fully support that he can be in
everything always
um
and then you know tim roth is his
character is directly tied to hulk he
tried to kill him i mean absolutely so
it's all very organic you know there was
no cameos for the sake of cameos
absolutely i will say that and i will
not say that any of them need to be
forced but you know again if some of
those ones happen i'm not gonna
um since you got to direct a lot of them
you obviously were very intimately
involved with the actors and the sort of
overall arc of the show is executive
producer as well but which episode are
you most excited to for an audience
reaction because i know
i think the reaction to the show in
general is going to be huge as far as
folks this is not going to be what they
expect but it's going to be really
delicious to watch them come along with
it but which episode in particular are
you looking forward to i mean obviously
the opening and the dynamic between uh
he-hulk and she-hulk um i love episode
four written by melissa hunter the
mystic castle i love um donnie blaze and
madison and wong uh you know i think
that should be a spin-off
that should you know he's gonna get a
spin-off he kind of has to at this point
otherwise it's like everyone else could
be like quit you're always here and
madison needs to be there calling him
longers yes that is actually awesome you
know that tag was actually added after
watching their comedic chemistry um on
the day just like really put them on a
couch and turn two cameras on them it's
where that uh you know sitcom training
came in handy because when you see that
kind of magic you gotta get it as much
as you can i was also gonna say too with
just the idea of the post credit scenes
for when you're directing those do they
have a different vibe from the rest of
the episode because they do really for
the episodes that have it really
accentuate the series um you know they
don't but they tend to be light-hearted
and have nothing to do with plot which
kind of frees you to find you know that
looseness that you're always looking for
when you're directing comedy the other
thing i was just gonna say too because
they've essentially set this up and so i
kind of have to ask it is this idea of
like you know we're here in los angeles
she-hulk is not but there's just this
idea of like some west coast type things
that could happen like the west coast
avengers kevin